μηχάσουμε μια λά αυτή τη στιγμή οι κύπρος ιδιος στην ιατρική έχε ένα σημαντικώ αλιθούμό
αποφείτων των ιατρικώ βασχολών και αυτά τα μιαλά που είναι καλήτρημαθητες που παστηνιατρική αυτά φεύγουν
από τον τόπου δικά μου την εξηδήεση στο εξωτερικό μα έχουμε τη δυνατό να εμείς
παραδιγμετα σχαριστώ γερμενικό να τους εκπαιδεύσουμε ζητούμε την έγκριση και τη δυνατότητ να μας δώσει
ν εξηδικήεύουμε αυτός τους αρς πλάμα που εκάμνα με δηλεδή στη γερμανία εξηχάσαμετ υγερουμε να
εξειδικευτηκαν στο κέντρο που ήμουν εγώ από μένα δεκάδες γιατρ μαλιστο με τα διδακτωρικά τους
ωρισμένοι τες έγινα και καθηγίτες υπάρχει αυτό το δυναμικό στην κύπρουπάρχει που μπορούμε να εξιδιεψουν
σε υψηλότατων επίπεδο ανοίξετε είμα στις πόρτες γιατί να φεύγουν αυτά τα μιαλά ακριμώς όταν
έκλεινα αυτή τηαυτό το πόταςο έκάνε εντύπωση ότι άκουσα από κάποιος που ήταν ανσθενή σας
γιατραότι όταν ξεπαιρνιούνταν τα δύσκολα τους βάζαται στο αμάξει και πηγαί να δεν πουζούκιαέτυχε και
αυτό τχ και αυτά όδιεμεργονται σχέσιηούντα άλλε σχές μέμε ε τους ασθενης δηναίοργουνται άλλες σχέσεις
είναι και ανάλογο με τον ασηλή τώρα να πηγαίνωστα που ζούκαι ήταν διεχολιςέτκ μια διαφορές
να το διασκεδάσουμε μαζί τάξι αυτό είναι ήτα σεαγωικάτο ξέσπαςμα στα όσαβιώσατε μαζί τους είναι
ένα ξέσπωσμε και είναι μια έας λόγος να διασκεδάσουμε μα επιτυχεία αλλά περιμένουμε τώρα προεγματικάδιμιοργηθεί
εντύπωση ότι με κάθε επιτυχία που έχουμε θα βγαίνωστα πουζκιαχοπβοτευτόότες είνότες στη λεμες όθανε συν
έχεια γιμάρτες γιατρέ αλλά ξαν όμως επειδή πριν ίπάμε ότι κάποιοι το έχουν δεμόνο οποιήσεις